keiko fujimori seguirá en libertad el
juez peruano víctor su única determinó
que la candidata presidencial no debe
volver a la cárcel por el caso de la
constructora brasileña odebrecht el
requerimiento del ministerio público de
ejemplo de que se revoque la comparación
es algo restricción si se dicte
nuevamente de prisión preventiva contra
la acusada keiko fujimori el fiscal
asegura que fujimori es la jefa de un
grupo de crimen organizado lavado de
activos obstrucción a la justicia y
declarar falsamente en medio un
procedimiento administrativo por lo que
pedía 30 años de prisión para ella y 22
para su esposo
[Música]
para nuestro país varios de sus
seguidores manifestaron su apoyo a los
acuerdos internos
la sesión se dio en medio un perú
polarizado que aún no conoce quién será
su próximo presidente el candidato
izquierdista pedro castillo tiene cerca
de 44 mil votos de ventaja sobre
fujimori pero aún no ha sido ratificado
como el ganador por el jurado nacional
de elecciones que continuaba volviendo
las apelaciones de las saques observadas
y los pedidos de nulidad presentados
después de las elecciones del 6 de junio